bonjour thierry clair merci de répondre
à nos questions en direct sur rt france
on vient de voir au micro de nadège
abderrazak des politiques des
manifestants à s'exprimer et dénoncer de
leurs mots à un blanc seing donné aux
autorités par rapport à ce texte
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez d'abord
chacun droit de manifester s'exprimer
les parlementaires débattent le texte de
la proposition de loi est actuellement
débattu au sénat leur revenir ensuite à
l'assemblée nationale il faut laisser le
législateur opéré justement le texte
qu'il souhaite présenter j'ai représenté
définitivement les débats ont lieu au
parlement au sénat aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale dans les semaines
qui suivront et je crois que ce qui est
important en tout cas ce que nous
demandons à l'unsa police c'est que les
policiers soient protégés
il s'agit pas de donner un blanc-seing
n'importe quoi il s'agit tout simplement
de la protection des policiers
c'est en fait c'est le le droit
simplement à l'image que nous
revendiquons nos collègues de travail
dans dans des difficultés aujourd'hui
qui sont reconnues de tous on est une
société qui est de plus en plus violente
on a vu avec tous les faits qui ont été
commis en corse ces dernières semaines
et état d'exemple nos collègues qu'ils
évoluent dans cette société
ils font face à des situations qui sont
difficiles à gérer il ne s'agit pas en
l'occurrence en ce qui concerne
l'article 24 d'interdire de filmer
d'ailleurs nous ce que nous fêtons à
l'unsa police et que tout juste et
théophile message est simplement je
dirais de protéger le visage des
policiers est en tout cas les intentions
malveillantes de ceux qui diffusent des
images en termes d'identification et
ensuite de menaces mais justement d'un
côté donc on va les manifestants qui
évoque une loi liberticide de l'autre
vous policier qui a appelé à ce que les
lois vous protège donc où est ce qu'il
faut placer le curseur pour que tout le
monde soit gagnant on voit des images
qui sont en direct en de cette
manifestation il faut placer le curseur
simplement dans cadre de la démocratie
que chacun puisse exprimer le droit de
manifester n'est pas remis en cause
chacun peut manifester il ya des règles
pour cela dans le rôle de la police il
faut leur préciser aussi le rôle d'un
policier s'est pas d'empêcher les
manifestations c'est d'encadrer
manifestation justement de façon à ce
que chacun puisse s'exprimer librement
dans le pays
c'est ça les fondements de la république
c'est aussi le fait de protéger ceux qui
protègent ceux qui viennent pour
manifester aussi on a vu lors de
l'ensemble d'un ensemble de
manifestations importantes des gens qui
viennent pour s'en prendre à tout ce qui
peut représenter l'état l'ordre en
l'occurrence la société et notamment ce
sont les policiers qui sont très souvent
les lampistes en fait de ces
manifestations voie avec des jets de
projectiles véritablement il ya des
dangers des mises en danger en tout cas
qui sont opérés vous avez de nos
collègues dont le rôle tout simplement
les images aussi pour aller à l'encontre
de ce que vous dites dans certaines
images qui ont pu être captée on a vu
également des faits ou l'igpn a été
saisie ou certains policiers et membres
des forces de l'ordre sont sont accusés
de faits de violence va avoir deux
bavures fini à +7 arty et c'est cet
article 24 et mise en place tel qu'il
est est ce que derrière il ya une une
loi liberticide comme justement scandent
tous et tous ces manifestants alors que
maintenant il ya le fameux mot un terme
provocation à l'identification ça change
maintenant par rapport à ce numéro 24
qu'est ce que vous vous en tirer comme
conclusion par rapport à tout ça et je
pense que d'abord il faut attendre
l'écriture définitive du texte
et est ce qu'il en ressort ce qui est
important véritablement c'est qu'il y
ait une protection pour le visage pour
l'image pour l'identification des
policiers qui ont aussi droit à une vie
privée et qui ont droit aussi à avoir de
la sérénité de la sérénité tout
simplement il s'agit absolument pas
d'empêcher finit d'ailleurs d'une serre
police nous avons demandé déjà depuis
des années à ce que la police et les
policiers soient équipés de caméras
piétons nous ce qu'on veut c'est pas
l'interdire de filmer ces comprimés
qu'on filme tout on en a assez de voir
des images qui sont diffusées
qui sont ces conseillers deux fois on a
vu avec des images qui sont bidouillées
avec des accélérations quelquefois de
façon à démontrer que les coûts sont
rapides et sont plus rapides parce
qu'ils n'ont été dans la réalité vous
que vous l'espérez tout en effet il faut
simplement fini filmé par le son par
l'image des choses quand vous dites
filmer tout c'est quoi ces les caméras
embarquées des policiers on en a entendu
parler
certaines qui fonctionne notre qui
fonctionne pas on parle également de
l'article 22 avec l'utilisation des
drones des aéronefs pour pouvoir filmer
d'en haut à voir tout ce qui se passe
c'est ça que vous évoquez notamment ce
sont effectivement des caméras piétons
telle théorie décrit bien on a des
caméras piétons qui ne sont pas du tout
perdre il ne fonctionne pas aujourd'hui
via un nouvel appel d'offres qui était
fait un marché qui est lancée avec des
sociétés qui ont présenté des modèles le
choix est en cours nous ce que l'on
souhaite c'est d'avoir du matériel qui
fonctionne qui marche
les policiers ils n'ont pas à se cacher
dans le cadre de leur mission ils
veulent pas se cacher et je dire ils
n'ont rien à craindre en tout cas de
d'être filmés et n'ont rien à craindre
des images ce qui donne simplement à ce
que nous voulons c'est une protection
par rapport aux identifications qui sont
portées de façon malveillance de façon à
nuire à nos collègues ou aux membres de
leur famille c'est ça en fait qui est
ciblé aujourd'hui c'est pour ce qui
concerne énoncé un consensus qui puisse
satisfaire toutes les parties et ne
léser personne à l'écouté en tout cas on
verra ce qu'il en ressort de l'art de
l'écriture définitive de cet article
notamment c'est vrai dans la proposition
de la sécurité globale il ya énormément
d'autres articles qui sont débattues et
actuellement on verra ce qu'il en
ressort est ensuite on pourra
véritablement se positionner je pense
qu'il faut laisser en tout cas les
choses se faire le sénat a largement
débattue est en train de débattre
aujourd'hui de nouveau ensuite le texte
reviendra à l'assemblée nationale il
faut effectivement je pense que là
dessus
la protection en tout cas des policiers
c'est quelque chose qui ne doit pas au
choc et qui compte
merci thierry clair d'avoir une poignée
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général adjoint du
syndicat unsa police